[Music]
and asking to get fired news submitted
by shake-and-bake
McDonald's employee was fired for
refusing to serve anyone with a badge
hmm it's like no we have no fireman no
no security guards
yeah no public sentiments pretty much
maybe he was looking out for their
health oh yeah like I don't want to give
you diabetes a lot of cholesterol here I
like that
so last Wednesday at a McDonald's
location in Florida a employee of
McDonald's told a group of paramedics
that they don't serve their kind here
will serve your kind here
well is it cause of paramedics or of a
certain race or was it because of the
badge it was specifically to officers
and anyone with the bat we don't serve
lifesavers here we don't do it I mean I
think in the wake of police brutality
that's probably where that person's come
from I'm just assuming could be and
they're so stupid that they thought that
the paramedics were here laughs yeah
they're like fat cats they're like did
they this person saved why so this
person said anyone with a badge
we don't serve them I don't do that so
there's people with breast cancer
awareness badges and they're like no
[ __ ] you we don't serve your kind or oh
it's got wood I just got my help my
grandmother badge nope yeah the senior
citizen security guard at Walmart [ __ ]
you yeah how long did this go on for
so this basically the paramedics took to
Facebook and it kind of got solved in a
Facebook amount of time Facebook outrage
amount of time I mean why did they just
call the manager yeah the [ __ ] it's a
cashier then did everybody were they all
like nah [ __ ] badges that's what one of
the paramedics say they say that they
regret taking a Facebook for this but
they really didn't know what to do it's
not
talk to the problem you just ask the
manager well because then the whole
McDonald's was basically like [ __ ] you
know they employees it that they're that
they were experiencing so I don't think
they're all the workers there no no just
the person they're all the McDonald's
employee they're doing you go to Carl's
jr. man I would have taken as a joke
like ha that's funny and if they were
serious I was like okay I'll go to the
next cashier dude be like I'm a
paramedic what the [ __ ] is your problem
like if you started choking right now I
would say I could save you I definitely
question like are you serious cuz I
think he's joking I would think he's
joking - so here's the post and you want
to read that geotag bit I'm at working
my sun.star paramedic uniform I walk
into McDonald's just she's the bathroom
and an employee goes we don't accept
officers in here I tell her I'm not an
officer she then says anyone with a
badge then says it to my partner as he
walks in to order food she says we don't
serve your kind here just in saying how
people are feel free to share and repost
that dumbass thought they were caught
yeah they did I like how she took it
into her own [ __ ] hand it's like this
is my story it's like [ __ ] it doesn't
work [ __ ] what they get to do that all
day think of it like you come in and you
don't buy anything and like you can't
use the bathroom [ __ ] you like the Kings
are their own Kingdom yeah it's crazy
that after they said we're not cops
they still stuck to it they're like
we're not officers so yeah then one of
the paramedics took to Facebook and you
can read that the events that occurred
the other night were unfortunate and my
frustration of the situation I took the
social media which probably wasn't the
best there were other ways to handle the
situation that could have been handled
better but that's my fault and I
apologize I understand the employee was
terminated and McDonald's took the
appropriate action thank you I will not
be answering phone calls from messages
about the interviews so please stop
blowing up my phone
I'm putting the situation behind me and
going to continue to help people to the
best of my ability
thank you cuz they get [ __ ] bugged by
the news every time she goes viral like
that they go can we get a quilt exactly
Anthony got him fired so that's just we
didn't you didn't help at all and then
I'll never understand why people go to
Facebook to complain about stuff like I
read all these news articles and they're
on Facebook right they're all from
Facebook or something and I'm like I'm
not that anything happens to me per se
but like [ __ ] I don't think I'm the type
of person to be like haha someone was
racist towards me we're feeling sick you
are MLA I don't think I'll ever do that
I don't understand why people cuz it
works it works [ __ ] works do they get
anything out of it though I guess they
got the person fired that way that's a
smack what about like dealing it with it
like in in the actual play talking to
the manager like resolving the conflict
instead of like that seems healthier
yeah people will want to tell a story
though I feel like at first this is just
something to vent about like every
poster we share you know like you have
zero followers and like you know I don't
think you have any expectations of it
blown up but then when it blows up oh
yeah there's like whoa oh [ __ ] you know
like I'm just sharing amongst my friends
I'm pretty sure this paramedic doesn't
do social media professionally and she's
like let me just tell this story a lot
of people use Facebook in different ways
yeah yeah and if you don't use Facebook
you might not know Facebook culture
because I just see a lot of people
complaining oh I've seen ubereats
drivers on Twitter being like damn I
only got a one dollar tip WTF and that's
all they wrote you know I mean but but
sometimes a story like that can just
blow the [ __ ] up and become this
national thing yeah yeah like when they
steal like from their tip jar or they
puke in their car or they like [ __ ]
they're drunk and they're like racist to
them or some [ __ ] we start whaling on
them or they get to the customer you
just don't know like you said everyone
wants to tell their story so everyone's
just trying to get their story out there
and then sometimes it actually hits ya
not shooting that's true cuz venting is
different from actually solving a
problem he was probably just trying to
vent about his day yeah yeah yeah
that's probably what it was well he's
like he's like a Facebook [ __ ] in
person but your point is just like why
didn't they ask for the manager and that
point the manager go you need to serve
well actually I remember I wanted to
complain to McDonald's one time I went
there years ago I was ordering chicken
nuggets and I said hey can I get a
barbecue sauce no I didn't order chicken
nuggets I just wanted a barbecue sauce
and they're like it's gonna be 25 cents
so I was like [ __ ] this I'm going inside
so I went inside I'm like yeah I asked
for a barbecue sauce and the lady's like
it's gonna be 25 cents I'm like I like
to speak to the manager
they're like I am the manager what you
do Facebook not me and gotten paid 25
and I was like this is [ __ ] and then
dude and then while you were gone she
spit on the fries sauce you know you
know what's fascinating to me is this is
like when you get Nuggets yeah you know
there's a sauce yeah what drives me
crazy is when you get Nuggets and
there's no sauce you almost can't eat
the minim you you're like I'm so angry
I'm Jes I'm like why the [ __ ] the
Nuggets are sauce holders bro but the
person who works there they had any
pride in their work
you'd be like even if the sauce was
incorrect how can you give the Nuggets
without sauce thanks you might as well
hand me an empty bag that's like give me
a cup with no drink inside how dare you
sweet sour yeah that's my sauce I like
to barbecue barbecue if we're talking
mcdonnen some sweet hot mustard yeah
what do you guys think about people not
wanting to serve people with badges at
all I think it's great I think the
opposite is kind of cool where you know
people with badges get a discount
because one you want cops and people at
your restaurants so they're like if a
robber comes or whatever you know they
it's my spot they're like oh [ __ ]
there's too many cops there and I don't
want to go robbed that place and most
places have insane discounts like movies
could be three bucks for a movie like
everything's like 50% yeah
yeah and assuming I mean that there they
are working for the community right so
you just you just wanna like if you own
the restaurant you just want paramedics
and cops and whatever to come down be
friends with them cuz if [ __ ] goes down
at your place you want them to come down
and be like hey what's up Joe oh [ __ ]
what's going on oh that's Joe's place we
gotta go and like help him out or
something it's weird to treat them like
they're the worst one you know what I
mean it's the one you read about in the
news the police brutality guys launched
it it's weird to treat just like like a
cop at your establishment like they're
that you're people you don't know you
don't know there's a whole new logic cuz
then the next day they they're they're
off to work and their regular clothes
civilian clothes they're walking in you
would serve your wine you'd be like oh
what's up man and yours your fries and
your drink and it's like the whole all
Muslims are terrorists thing or like all
it's like all cops or [ __ ] you know
[ __ ]
you really don't I mean and there's what
millions of cops are something out in
America alone like there's a [ __ ] ton of
cops right so how can you live one
action kind of dictate how they all are
I think just cuz it's been happening for
so long you know and it's right now it's
been highlighted a lot so people are
just kind of hilar you're gonna hear
about some of the crimes that are
happening to cops like people are out
there just killing them when they're not
in uniform like oh I remember his face
oh there he is pulling that they don't
even they don't even talk about it
that's true like when I'm researching
for articles too you know for JK news in
general what if like I work with her
behind the scenes and I'm like looking
up news articles tonight I you hear
about like cops shooting that guy or
shooting her you know and then and then
I'll occasionally come across articles
were unlike the cop died and I'll read
about it I'm like Oh gangbanger still
exist in this world
they're targeting cops or like you know
and you see all these things that are
happening to cops and cops have their
funerals and they're marching through
the street so I'm like oh [ __ ] this is
this this is the other half of the stuff
but no one ever highlights it no it's
not it's not the [ __ ] it's not sexy
for the media yeah cuz I mean we know
like we have friends who have cops and
stuff and we also know that there are
incidents just right honor free right
here where there was a guy that he
didn't want to go back to jail so when
he got pulled over and a cop came up to
ask him for his license they just shot
him in the face and drove off so that's
why they're like why
so trigger-happy and paranoid if I knew
that my partner just got shot from a
traffic violation I think I'd be as
paranoid - yeah each other's eyes every
stop every stop you could get blown away
playing Russian roulette I just never
know what's gonna happen and that's
where I'm like ah man it just sucks cuz
then when you see both sides it's hard
to be like it's someone's it's your
fault for doing something it's like man
I'm not even in your world that shit's
crazy dude I've been watching a bunch of
[ __ ] about the OJ stuff like Oh J trial
stuff and it's kind of [ __ ] crazy how
I think back then the cops definitely
tried to plant evidence yeah that's
something - yeah it's real I mean in
that I think it was the 80s or 90s where
the LAPD got caught actually planting
crack on specifically black people what
has that joke were yeah every every
person and then when you when that kind
of history exists it's like then there's
a distrust of the police from the
community and it's like why would you
want to call the cops they're gonna
plant crack on you like Oh J probably
killed with Nicole right like everyone
accepts that but there was so much
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] that they were able
to easily convince a jury like hey this
is really suspect it's like making a
murder where even if even Avery did it
because the costs planted [ __ ] and [ __ ]
with evidence
it looks like shady yeah so I mean it's
just so hard to tell what who's right
and who's wrong you know but I highly
recommend there's a there's a couple
videos that they did and I think it was
in early 2000s or I was just after the
OJ trial ended and it's OJ himself
giving all the counter points to his
entire trial no way it's [ __ ] dope I
watched all of himself doing OJ and a
yellow sweater and he's like he's like
yeah so like Marcia Clark told you this
[ __ ] but did she tell you this [ __ ] and
like you're like wow I didn't even think
of that it's very interesting stuff so
he's writing himself oh is it true I see
I mean he could be lying seems really
cogent like arguments like he basically
takes you through the whole thing he was
the argument for himself is argue for
the other side he's argue for the
defense he's telling you a lot of things
that the media
after he was it what would media do
during his entire trial they inflated
every little thing that they found but
they found blood drops at OJ's house and
then OJ takes you to where the blood
tops were found in this house means like
here's why that's [ __ ] and it's
really interesting [ __ ] that's one of my
like vivid early memories is watching
the highway chase because there was the
year the Knicks were playing the Rockets
and the NBA Finals
I remember seeing with my brother and
then cut it they cut away no DVR back
then yeah I remember my brother audibly
gonna what doll [ __ ]
and I was like three years old and
helicopters followed well so my buddy's
house right it was right here in the
freeway was like right there so we could
see the freeway from our house from the
from his house we're on the front lawn
and he passed by the high-speed pursuit
happened right in front of us yeah it
was crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]